all right let's go back to the phones
let's go to sarah in
toronto canada sarah good
morning from the united states how are
we doing
good morning hi dr john thanks so much
for taking my call
thank you for calling how can i help you
this morning
okay so i went through um a really
traumatic c-section
um about 15 months ago man i'm so sorry
yeah um so about like i said 13 months
ago i went to labor
everything seemed fine at first this was
my second
child um towards the 10 hour mark they
noticed his heart rate
dropping fast and they weren't sure what
was wrong with him and they
just made the quick decision to rush me
into the or
so i didn't really have time to process
this whole thing
um when they started um
i felt everything about my c-section
i felt them cutting i felt
hard sorry it's hard for me to talk
about but um i felt some cutting i felt
them moving my organs
i saw everything um i remember pleading
with the anesthesiologist
um pleading with my husband he was in
the room he
was having a hard time hearing me
because i was just so weak i remember
going in and out of consciousness
blacking out a lot
um i felt like i was having panic
attacks um while they were having
surgery
while i was having the surgery um the
whole thing lasted about eight minutes
and towards the end they finally drug me
up with something i just knocked out for
hours
um so now uh you know a little over a
year
um i just get really intense flashbacks
thankfully they're not daily i can look
at my son i can see my scar and i'm not
traumatized daily but i get the random
flashbacks and i just don't know how to
move past
um and brings up a lot of anxiety for
future surgeries
um a lot of fear attached to it as well
um that was my first ever surgery and
i just don't know how i would handle the
thought of having another one
or having more kids in case i need
another c-section
um so i just would like if you have any
advice
to um to give yeah there's a lot here
first and foremost that sucks nobody
should ever have to go through that
and i want you to know sarah that's not
the way it's supposed to be
and i hate that you went through that
okay
i want you to hear that the second thing
is is
one of my little throwaway lines my
little um
i don't know their little pinteresty
quotes that don't mean a whole lot
actually mean something in this moment
and anxiety is fear of the future
right it's this this inability to
control what's what's happening
um especially what come what may we
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow the next day or the next day
in your case this transcends anxiety
this is true fear because you have been
in a situation where you lost control
and the people that we all as a
community as
a culture trust to take care of us in
those moments
medical professionals they failed you
okay and i don't think they failed you
on purpose i don't think
anybody ceases i mean enters those
moments to do that
but the goal there is just to protect
you and to protect that baby
and thankfully they were there to
help that baby and to take care of that
baby but
man you had surgery performed on you
without anesthesia and you remember it
and so these flashbacks are ways that
your body reminds you to never let that
happen again
and that's the work that you need to do
have you gone to see somebody
um i know a lot of my family members
have told me to
speak with my doctors to get the
therapist um i think my fear
with that is i don't want to be put in
a dark place i don't know i know it's
going to be a journey
i know it's not going to be a one quick
fix
one session i can go to so i know i need
to go through it
for a while and i just my mind i'm not
sure if i can handle that
i know that's what you need to do but
it's just hard to
to think of speaking about it often and
going
to that dark place often but yeah i know
i need to speak with someone
so here's the thing with an acute trauma
like this
an acute means like a laser beam or a
razor think about it very sharp and
direct okay
with an acute trauma the exit
is often not as lengthy and painful as
you think it might be you are
right you're going to have to go there
if you find a great
therapist who can do things like emdr or
i've seen some neat stuff with brain
spotting even tfcbt which is
trauma-focused
cognitive behavioral therapy it's
usually for children but in moments like
this can be really powerful
you're not talking a whole bunch of
sessions you're talking about 10 or 11
and those sessions are broken up in how
to talk
to yourself how to learn to
self-regulate when those thoughts pop in
your head
and then you go through that trauma
again and then you go out the back end
of it
and there's a remarkable cathartic
moment the the
research efficacy on those programs is
really extensive it's really
extraordinary
emdr moments to help you your brain
reset itself i want you to do a fun
exercise for me okay
okay um so i want you to close your eyes
and i'm going to take this directly from
david kessler who's the
the grief and trauma expert on planet
earth
i want you to close your eyes and i want
you to picture a purple elephant
okay okay i want you to picture a purple
a purple elephant in your driveway
just standing there with a hat on his
head okay do you have that picture in
your head
yeah okay i want you to open your eyes
now what you have just done
is prove to america and the entire world
that you can control your thoughts
okay and so what a
counselor will help you do in these
moments is control those intrusive
painful thoughts that firebomb into your
head out of nowhere
and what you will learn is that it's
like a muscle and that over time you
will be able to
slowly and you'll slowly grow that
muscle to where you are stronger and
stronger when that thought pops in there
you see your baby and by this time he's
gonna be riding a tricycle around
and you flash to that moment you'll be
able to go nope
not doing it and literally you can you
can
move it out but that's like me telling
you right now how you can just go to a
crossfit gym and just crank out 75
pull-ups
right you've got to practice that and
you need a coach and you need someone to
walk alongside you and that's what a
therapist is going to do
if you walk into a counselor and they
tell you
all right i want you to tell me
everything that happened on session one
just say thank you but i'm gonna leave
because you're not a good trauma
counselor you don't know what you're
doing and people can re-injure you
and like you said make things pretty
dark if they don't know what they're
doing
but i want you to find i guarantee you
in toronto there are some extraordinary
trauma counselors
that you can talk about your situation
they will help you walk
out of that situation with a set of
skills
to begin to take control of your
thoughts to begin to
reframe some of those moments and really
just stop the intrusion
because surgery can be an extraordinary
thing it can be a really remarkable gift
and occasionally occasionally it's a
painful painful trauma
so again sarah i am so sorry that
happened to you that sucks
and here's the other thing don't lose
the trauma here too
there's this innate trauma that my body
didn't work like it was supposed to
and i've known a number of women who
carry around a deep deep trauma that's
beyond the physical trauma which is why
did my body do what it was supposed to
do
and make sure you discuss that with your
counselor as well
this idea that my body is supposed to be
a machine it's supposed to
a plus b is supposed to equal c our
bodies don't work like that
they're still beautiful they're still
extraordinary and sometimes things
happen
and that's when the medical community is
supposed to come in and help us and
unfortunately didn't go well for you
this time
please reach out to somebody again emdr
tfcbt if you can find somebody that will
do a modified version that for you as an
adult
find a trauma counselor in your area
bite down on your mouthpiece head into
the ring there do the hard work to go
get well
it will be worth it on the back end for
you for your husband
for those beautiful beautiful kids of
yours and for whatever adventure you are
going to co-create moving down the road
thank you so so much for your call sarah
you're a gift and a blessing thank you
for calling